[Music]
I'm Kimba seen luxury reporter at
Bloomberg here to invite you into the
most exclusive realms of luxury retail
this is invitation only
today I'm in Chelsea
the Manhattan neighborhood with
everything a fancy person could ask for
tons of super expensive art a bustling
pricy market and a formerly posh hotel
turned historic landmark once home to
notable fancy guests like Lillie Langtry
milos forman Jane Fonda and Bette Midler
so with its knack at preserving old
beautiful things it shouldn't be a
surprise that Chelsea is also home to
the world's fanciest used clothing shop
New York vintage so we're in our retail
store right now to the bottom floor
which is open to the public and anybody
can come in and shop and purchase these
wonderful rare pieces of vintage and
then the second floor is a private
showroom that houses over 150 years of
important fashion Milan see agha Halston
scaparelli for to me worth really
special rare pieces that are Museum
caliber basically impossible to come by
downstairs all these pieces are for sale
upstairs there for red who shops up
there who's allowed up in the treasure
trove we work with editors and stylists
for industry use but we have a lot of
our private clientele celebrities that
will come up for fittings for various
events as well what kind of celebrities
every time the a-list kind
do your dresses show up on the red
carpet all the time yeah absolutely
yeah and to see the clothing kind of
take on a different life is incredible
to get an appointment upstairs can
anyone just walk in or call you and get
an appointment to go to go check it out
it's not that easy you have to have
credentials you vet people leave that
people everyone is vetted before they
have access to the archive absolutely am
I allowed out there I'll let you have a
peek I'll give you a little guided tour
look at this ready to be inspired uh-huh
so over here we have an Adrian this is
1930s he designed costumes for over 250
films during Hollywood's golden era Jean
Harlow Joan Crawford and Garbo all of
these ladies wore his gowns he's known
for this silhouette bias
nineteen-thirties dress these are
corsets from the 1880s 1880s uh-huh
1880s we have some examples of some
McQueen head pieces over here we have
Gianni Versace back here we have a bra
that was worn by Lady gaga
I believe this was disparate editorial
just aware just to wear Gaga of course
and by the way this belonged to
Josephine Baker
so this bras from the 1920s a lot of
famous breasts were at this Rack will
act this rack No so this is the famous
Sarah Jessica Parker Sex and the City
Bert
has anyone tried to buy this off of you
I would say the most interesting
solicitation was from a Saudi princess
who was buying up everything from sex
and city of the film and offered a very
large sum of money of course we turn it
down and how large is large six figures
yeah it was buried yes for this little
bird I've had some moments where I've
realized the impact we've had on the
fashion industry I can share an
experience a few years ago where I was
up in my showroom just working away I
had my three children running around me
and I get a call on my cell phone from
the White House we'd like to put
Michelle Obama and vintage just never
knowing what or who you're working with
knowing that somehow you inspired
someone to take an idea and to run with
it
so you're hearing all this talk about
the retail apocalypse retailers died how
is that affecting this business it's so
scary I've been here for almost 20 years
and I don't think that anybody on my
block is really standing since we first
opened and I think that the reason why
we haven't really been impacted is
because it is an experience when you
come here we've been asked by schools to
have private tours we've opened our
archives to students for research you
just feel good coming in and you feel
like you've walked into a time capsule
of fashion history all in one place
[Music]
you